well if you look at the history of the
automobile there have never really been
any radical changes I don't see any
radical changes or step changes in the
near future at least but I think we're
perhaps we will see some bigger changes
than in the past I believe that if we're
going to continue to use automobiles in
any big way we have to be much more
selective as end users in making sure we
use the right vehicle for the right job
the right tool for the right job the
right car for the right journey and you
mentioned a little earlier you know how
85 87 percent of people still use the
car for their commuting rather than
other means of transportation so then
reality is that most of those car
journeys are done alone so why do we
haul around ourselves in a vehicle
that's 20 or 30 times our own weight
because it's got three four or five six
seven sometimes empty seats around us
those vehicles are fine when they used
to carry a lot of people but so I think
one of the changes that I believe we
need to see as a much greater
opportunity for people to to use whether
it's through buying or sharing vehicles
specifically for commuting there'll be
as safe they'll be much more energy
efficient use up less space and then you
can make a better case for using cards
so i think the architecture of vehicles
will will will start to see much smaller
vehicles i think that one of the one of
the big issues of the vehicle design to
is the crash of Odin's technology that
we're beginning to see being introduced
personally my own opinion is that if the
automobile is to remain a major player
in personal mobility then I think
autonomous vehicles are going to be a
real a real advantage some people think
this is crazy and is not possible
I and quite a few other people think
that this is not crazy and there are
some really good reasons why we should
go that way we're kind of on the way now
how will this affect the way cars look
as I've said we're going to see cars
that I hope we see more cars on the road
that are much smaller we've seen some
examples at recent auto shows Volkswagen
and some of the Japanese companies have
shown much smaller vehicles there is
still a lot of reticence amongst car
users that they're not as safe was
driving around in a big car that needn't
be the case small cars can be engineered
to be extremely safe they still have to
pass all the same crash regulations that
a big car does so a lot of it is about
perceptions at the same time if cars can
be engineered to drive themselves
reliably without crashing into each
other then you can make the cars a lot
lighter still because you don't have to
engineer them to be like tanks
I think given the right circumstances we
could see vehicles that are able to
drive by themselves in within a decade
but that's under ideal circumstances the
the main barrier that people flag up
with autonomous driving is yes but how
do you mix cars that can drive
themselves with older cars that can't
drive themselves and so actually
introducing these autonomous cars into
the legacy fleet is that is the is a
challenge that I believe it's quite
possible honestly I think it's probably
20 or 30 years away before we see a
landscape a car landscape where all cars
are driving themselves but I often think
what would it be like if we if we
transported ourselves and a hundred
years into the future or imagine our
great-great-grandchildren and they say
granddad is it true that in twenty ten
people were allowed to drive their own
cars around yep that's absolutely true
now say well that's crazy did people
crash into each other and make mistakes
yes they did and forty thousand people a
year died every year on the American
roads because they crashed into each
other and goodness knows how many people
got injured Wow so how is that allowed
to last for so long I think if you look
at that perspective you can see it
becomes an inevitability that but I
would say 20 or 30 years before it
becomes ubiquitous but I think we can we
see it we see the beginnings of it now
there are a lot of vehicles now which
have adaptive speed control on there and
on the cruise control adaptive cruise
control of the car gets too close to the
one in front the brakes automatically
come on most people who drive very
powerful sports cars have subliminal
systems built into the car which apply
the brakes a little bit discreetly or or
stop the wheel spinning of the drivers
too enthusiastic or too aggressive we
have devices that warn you if you tried
change lanes when there's somebody is
still in your blind spot and we also
have now and some cars that being
introduced that if the car feels that
you have not seen a pedestrian step out
in front of you or it's getting too
close to a stationary object it'll slam
on the brakes without the driver before
the driver even reacts so you imagine
these kinds of technologies becoming
more and more ubiquitous in the cars so
that the car kind of in the end
surreptitiously takes over from the
driver then you can see the driver
beginning to take less and less interest
in the driving and that to me is the way
we introduce them into the legacy fleet